because the network provider makes
assumptions about how people will use
their service and it's on based on those
assumptions that allows them to what's
called multiplex their provision so
instead of having to give every
individual the 100 megabits a second
that you think you've bought they
actually only have some proportion of
that and they just assume that you're
actually not going to use it you're not
in fact going to be using it under
percent the time at full pull rate and
so what they can then do is they can
kind of overlay sort of when you're
quiet somebody else is getting that
bandwidth when they're quiet you're
getting that bandwidth if you've got the
total capacity and you've got lots and
lots of subscribe subscribe is coming in
there's some of there's lots lots of
houses individuals at the end of this if
we were all using this at full rate all
the time so we're all going then it just
wouldn't fit right you because your
buddy you're only going to have
relatively speaking a small amount out
of here so that's got some numbers on
this so let's say here you've got one
gigabit a second some picking things out
of thin air and each of these is 100
megabits a second and there are 50
subscribers on this if everybody was
going at full rate all the time you'd
have five gigabits coming in here only
one gigabit coming out and that won't
fit I think we're going to get loss they
can get congestion and increase the
delays because essentially all the
packets are gonna end up queuing up and
eventually because this is a finite size
cube you can't have an infinite memory
in this some of the packets are going to
end up getting dropped so you'll get
loss because this queue is going to be
full you'll have lots of extra delay
because the packets are going to come in
at the back and they can have to wait to
get to the front to go through so when
you're overloaded like that this is what
causes loss it causes delay and it makes
the user experience suck because it
means that when you're trying to get
data from a side of you trying to
transmit requests to a site it takes a
long time for anything to happen because
you have to retransmit the lost data and
you've got to kind of deal with all this
however in practice it's unlikely that
all of the users are going to be using
it at 100% at the rate understand the
time so so long with you've got you know
some users can be busy and then some
users are sort of going to be quiet and
maybe just use it a little bit and then
some users will be bursty users like
this it'll all kind of fit
together on average and everybody will
be okay so this is called statistical
multiplexing that you're fitting things
together like this if you end up in a
situation like here for example where
everybody builds happen to use it
significantly all at the same time so
for instance they're watching an online
stream live streams watching Larry more
commonly a lot plots at the I experience
this on with my ISP that if I come home
in the evening sometime between about 5
o'clock and 8 o'clock things are often a
bit slower and that works not so good
and that's not because my level of
access has changed it's because
everybody is using it at that time and
so which is busy homework watching films
watching iPlayer whatever it might be
and you can so you've got these kind of
cueing effects that happen where there's
just lots of data trying to get through
the pipe cues build up congestion builds
up things slowed down a bit you start
seeing packet loss most of the time that
doesn't happen and so most the time
device piecing get away with selling
each of you a hundred megabits a second
even though they couldn't actually deal
with it if everybody use that all the
time so that they're playing a bit well
a bit of a gambling game but they're
also mitigating costs against that so if
you have wanted guarantee bamberd like
you're a business then you pay more
because you paying for that guarantee
and indeed does I mean it is kind of a
gambling game explicitly in that there's
a lot of maths that goes into this of
studying these kind of traffic patterns
and trying to work out what these
traffic patterns are going to be and how
things going to behave and what kind of
ratios you can get away with here and
still provide decent service and one of
the things that makes it particularly
difficult in the internet so this this
kind of process been on the phone
network for decades hundreds of years
oh yeah probably over on road user and
the nice thing about phone calls is that
they follow a certain pattern so there
are certain statistical distributions
probability distributions you can apply
to that so it's the price on
distribution is a good way of modeling
the arrivals right of phone calls so
there's some random period of time then
you get a phone call coming
and that random period of time follows a
distribution and that distribution is
quite amenable to mathematical analysis
and so you can do lots of quite detailed
planning of how big you have to build
things and what you've got to cope with
there one of the problems with the
internet is that because of the way that
the data is put into packets and then
transmitted essentially the
distributions of those kind of arrival
times of data of packets at a particular
point in the network are much much less
amenable to analysis and it becomes very
difficult to manipulate that and plan
for what's going to happen because at
any given moment thing more things could
happen than you expected to kind of
thing and so it's much harder to do that
kind of analysis if everything's kind of
random and independent it's typically
easier to deal with whereas if you've
got lots of things happening at the same
time because they kind of naturally all
happen together it means you can have
quiet periods and then massive amount of
stuff happen and then quiet period of
massive map stuff happen
instead of just having things kind of
chugging along at random in the
background and so you get lots of
correlated arrival so because the way
that some of these online protocols work
for example there's a tendency for their
Ida to be nothing or a burst of packets
all one after the other and that kind of
bursty behavior means that you tend to
get quiet periods and they're very very
busy periods rather than having some
kind of background have originally busy
kind of period as a user throws it so
that's quite a bad thing in the sense
that because of that kind of effect it's
hard to work out for the ISP to work out
how to big-big to build everything and
how close to the bone they can cut this
essentially which means that it you will
from time to time experience slowdowns
and things if you're not paying extra
money for the guaranteed bandwidth
what's going to happen is you've got
some data that starts out in your
browser so that's the request and then
that's going to get sent down through
these libraries eventually into the
operating system and what's going to
happen there is that this chunk which is
your original data maybe he's going to
get encoded as a TCP segment